President Trump meanwhile unveiling a
new rapid test kit for a corona virus
that is supposed to give results within
five minutes of taking it yesterday's
announcement coming just days after
manufacturer Abbott Labs said that the
FDA had given them emergency clearance
to produce its cartridge-based tests
chief White House correspondent John
Roberts joining us now live with more on
that John good morning Sandra good
morning to you and the president very
excited about this new rapid five-minute
test from Abbott Labs displaying it
there in the Rose Garden of the White
House we expect to get more details
today on what the new guidelines
regarding social distancing will be it
will be in place until April the 30th
and the data behind those at the daily
coronavirus briefing in the Rose Garden
yesterday the president indicating that
he received a startling forecast from
his medical team about what could happen
if those guidelines were relaxed too
early I asked the president whether the
guidelines would be the same or if they
would be modified listen here we may had
a few more but the guidelines would be
very much as they are maybe even
toughened up a little bit but they're
having a big impact this is based on
modeling that shows the peak in
fatalities will not arrive for another
two weeks the same modeling also shows
that by very vigorously following these
guidelines we could save more than 1
million American lives
the president also saying that the
current restrictions on travel and
border restrictions will stay in place
travel restrictions from the EU are up
for reconsideration on April the 13th
travel restrictions across the u.s.
Mexico and Canada borders up for renewal
on April the 22nd the president
suggesting yesterday that there will not
be any change there now the White House
continues to work with private
corporations to ramp up and deliver
desperately needed medical supplies the
president announcing that drug companies
will be making available some 17 million
doses of chloroquine to treat patients
also announcing that Ford Motors has
partnered with General Electric to
produce 50,000 ventilators in the next
100 days I asked the president about
that to listen here so we have now
ten companies at least making the
ventilators and we say go ahead do you
believe as we approach this peak in a
couple of weeks that there will be
enough for the American Pie yes I do
think so I think we're gonna be in very
good shape and more information from the
coronavirus Task Force on how long we
will be dealing with this virus dr.
Anthony found she's saying that he
expects that like the flu corona virus
will come back again in the fall but
that it will be a very different
situation listen here I would anticipate
that that would actually happen because
of the degree of transmissibility
however if you come back in the fall it
will be a totally different ballgame of
what happened when we first got hit with
it in the beginning of this year there
will be several things that will be
different our ability to go out and be
able to test identify isolate and
contact trace will be orders of
magnitude better than what it was just a
couple of months ago it's going to be
things that we have available to us that
we did not have before yeah one of those
things hopefully will be a vaccine as
well no the president yesterday in the
Rose Garden had with him the CEOs of a
number of different companies who are
pitching in to help out particularly
when it comes to personal protective
equipment the CEO of United Technologies
saying that his company will be making
available personal protective equipment
that it already has in its stockpiles as
well it will be making face masks as
well the CEO saying he does not need the
defense production act to get his
company to move the president will be
having a teleconference this afternoon
with Network service providers and then
of course Sandra at five o'clock will
have the daily coronavirus briefing
we'll see what that brings later on
today thank you
thank you for your reporting on all of
that John Roberts at the White House
safe